the fact that el salvador was able to
turn on the laser eyes across south and
central america should not be lost i
didn't want to uh interrupt you when
you're on your your
yeah
bitcoin hit 43k while you were uh well
you were talking there some people are
freaking out
um
stop stop trying to date you don't seem
worried
not am i not worried i'm about to pull
up and i might go buy some you should
buy an extra 30 worth whale
[Music]
maybe i crashed the price this morning
who knows
it hit 43 000 yeah wow i was already
back i'm talking it's already back up to
46. somebody just bought a lot of
bitcoin good for them i wish that i had
been paying attention i could have
bought some could have bought some more
what do you guys think about el salvador
i think it's good right like uh one of
the things i thought was interesting was
the the idea that every citizen can get
30 worth of bitcoin when they uh
download the chivas app so i was looking
up earlier in the average citizen takes
home after tax is about 400 to 450 per
month so 30 is significant enough to
where they're actually going to go and
download it i think
to be determined uh kind of what
percentage of people actually go and do
this and who uses it for payments we
obviously see that businesses already
right mcdonald's is obviously ready and
people are already using it
as a means of exchange there so now it's
really just convincing a bunch of
citizens to go out download the app
start using it in their everyday lives
and i think what we'll see over time is
like people will realize how easy it is
so you see these videos pop up whether
it's on bitcoin beach or kind of
different businesses whether it's in el
salvador or not it's actually very very
easy to transact if everything's set up
appropriately so i think uh when people
download the app they may do it at first
just to go and get that 30 of bitcoin
right because it's significant enough to
them from a financial standpoint to go
and actually get the money and then
secondly i think when they go to use uh
bitcoin as a medium of exchange they're
going to realize that it's much easier
than they would have expected and as the
price uh
obviously not right now in the last 10
or 15 minutes but as if the price
continues to appreciate over time
they're going to see their purchasing
power increase which they are not used
to and is going to be another means for
them to continue to use it as a currency
so i think it's good i think the
incentive that they're using to get them
to download uh their app in the wallet
and use bitcoin is good and it's smart
because they'll actually go out and do
it and then it's just kind of chugging
along and making sure that they continue
to implement ways for people to use it
make it easy to transact with and
everything like that and i think over
time uh kind of the the percentage of
the population in el salvador that uses
it will pick up
john what do you think kelly's a legend
for his twitter antics last night i
loved it uh live feed of what the
country's doing personally um i don't
think it's very surprising that the
country bought bitcoin right um they're
clearly heavily invested in innovation
that bitcoin can provide
and i think we're gonna see it going
forward that more countries if not have
already done it will look at bitcoin as
a way um
to put it on there like federal reserve
sheet or whatever it is
they're going to buy much more than 400
bitcoin right way more yeah they they
are uh starting with 150 million dollars
worth of bitcoin oh that's as they said
okay yeah so maybe maybe they just
picked up a little bit right there but
who knows but they're buying they
already they already had 150 million
dollars no they have two they have 21
million right now right after the 400 so
that's eight to ten times more they're
going to be purchasing at least
exactly gotcha
he's probably buying right
now i mean maybe who knows if you think
oh
breaking news breaking news
the president just tweeted what did he
say
wow i'm buying is that he said buying
the dip 150 new coins at it
wow
wow you know what that that deserves
there's only one thing that you have to
tweet when somebody tweets something
like that showing up to the bitcoin
scene and just starts tweeting
immediately saying buying the dip
he's gonna light the internet on fire
this guy
i just retweeted it with goat emojis
the president of el salvador just said
buying the dip winkface 150 new coins
added
bitcoin day what an entry price
absolutely aping into bitcoin
while it falls look at that the best
business show we are all over one minute
ago we tweeted
30 minutes on the screen if that doesn't
deserve a like and a subscribe i don't
know what else does
this is the future of where this is all
going price wants to move no problem
nation states are literally buying the
bitcoin dip
what else do you want are you not
entertained yet
by jesus
this is where the world is moving
because
it is a decentralized programmatic
transparent monetary policy and when you
start to understand what this nation is
doing when you start to understand that
they are simply saying this is also
legal tender we have the us dollar the
dollar is good for a lot of things but
we also now have a global store of value
that no one no one can devalue
it is incredible to watch that happen
what other president
the president of the united states all
of them regardless of what office they
come from or what party they come from
they don't know how to tweet this fast
even trump who literally built this
presidency on twitter he couldn't tweet
this fast
literally
making nation state decisions on
purchases of bitcoin as the price falls
in real time
oh wait oh we got more updates tweet
it appears the discount is ending thanks
for the dip imf news we saved a million
in printed paper el salvador now holds
550 bitcoin what a legend
what a legend
while buying the bitcoin dip we are
watching the first president of a nation
to buy bitcoin in real time saying
we saved a million dollars in printed
paper el salvador now owns
550 bitcoin thanks for the dip at imf
where else do you get this kind of
content on the air this is awesome i'm
gonna look up what cnbc is talking about
right now oil prices cnbc is a partner
of the best business show we've
outsourced our research to them they're
fantastic we really appreciate them uh
the the crazy part about this
is
what
say it say it they're talking about the
wage gap in tech companies right now
the wage gap in tech sorry you want to
know what the wage gap is bitcoin
[Music]
how long ago was this one oh he can't
see it was three minutes ago
i mean buchelli if you want to tweet
stuff just send it to us before you
tweet it next time like we don't even
need to wait till then
look
in all seriousness this is absolutely
ridiculous that we are watching a nation
state in real time literally in real
time by
bitcoin do we think he's he's doing it
on his cell phone
oh he's tweeting from his cell phone yes
the president of a country is tweeting
from his iphone
probably underneath the desk during a
meeting
saying thanks for the dip at imf i love
how he's got the hashtag he's got it
he's ready to go yeah oh man we saved a
million printed papers are we gonna
start doing this hold on man i'm gonna
send you i'm gonna send you this can you
pull this up real quick mackenzie
collins i i'm assuming that he is uh
watching right now uh just sent me a
meme and said this is what pomp thinks
is happening this morning in el salvador
and he's got a just unreal meme that uh
uh is going through here
is this what's happening in el salvador
is this what's happening
he's oh price went down
what's up guys bang bang thanks so much
for watching the best business show
today if we're gonna be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you 10 in bitcoin for free it's that
simple head on over to sofi.com to get
started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]